-Our next guest is the host
of the Colum Tyrrell Podcast
available on YouTube.
Making his television debut,
please welcome the very funny
Colum Tyrrell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi. How's it going?
[ Cheers ]
I'm -- I'm from Ireland, okay?
So I'm not as ugly as I look.
[ Laughter ]
People see me, they go, "Oh."
And then they hear me speak,
and they go,
"Actually, for an Irish guy,
not too bad."
[ Light laughter ]
You know "Game of Thrones?"
They filmed that in Ireland.
They did that to save on make-up
costs with the extras.
[ Laughter ]
The filming crew showed up
and were like,
"Hey, street merchant
with leprosy,
we're ready for your scene.
Come on."
[ Light laughter ]
That guy was like,
"No, I work with catering."
And they said, "Get in here,
you ugly pig, we need you."
Bring all your friends
and your family
because we need some wildings
for free."
[ Laughter ]
If you rewatch that show
and look in the background,
you'll see a bunch
of Irish plumbers and stuff,
staring at the camera.
[ Laughter ]
Every time a dragon flies by,
they waved.
[ Laughter ]
I love ugly people.
I was a waiter for years.
I never had an ugly person
complain about anything.
It's always
a good-looking person who wants
to speak to the manager,
usually a beautiful woman.
She would be like, "I ordered
my steak medium rare
and this is medium-medium-Rare."
[ Laughter ]
Ugly people,
they never complain.
They're just happy to be out
of the house.
[ Laughter ]
They ordered a steak
medium rare.
You can just throw a fish
at their head.
You wouldn't even need to kill
the fish.
Just lob it towards their ugly
face, and they'll catch it
in their fang like, hyah!
And then they break its neck.
And they'll smile at you
as fish guts dribble down
their ugly chin
onto their ugly body
because they're happy
for the eye contact.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love -- I love ugly people.
I want ugly kids
because you don't have to parent
ugly children.
Life will teach them
their lessons naturally.
[ Laughter ]
I'm dating an American girl.
We've been together for 5 years
now, so we're almost done.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Ah, she's all right.
She's okay.
She's into the environment
though,
and she recently bought
some coffee cups
that say "Save the Bees."
The bees, guys -- oh, God,
the bees are -- they're dying.
[ Laughter ]
And you can't go outside of
your house anymore
without piles of
dead bees everywhere you go.
And if the bees die, there'll be
no more Internet or something.
I don't know.
I zone out when she talks.
But it's important.
It's -- I'm told it's important.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, every morning, we drink
coffee from these coffee cups
that say "Save the Bees,"
alright?
I don't know what you guys are
doing, but we're helping.
[ Laughter ]
Recently -- recently, there was
a dead bee on our windowsill,
and my girlfriend is like,
"We have to save the bee."
And I go, "Yeah,
but he's already dead.
He must not have seen
the coffee cups
because that is a dead bee
if ever I saw one."
But apparently -- she explained
to me, apparently,
a lot of the time when you see
a dead bee,
apparently it's
not actually dead.
Most of the time, it's actually
just really thirsty
and he's having a little
dehydrated nap.
And it will die,
but you can save its life
by giving it a drink.
This is the type of ridiculous
stuff that comes out of her face
all of the time.
But I can't leave her
because I need a visa.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, I prepared -- I prepared
a dead bee drink
because I love this country.
[ Laughter ]
And I got tap water.
And she goes, "Not tap water.
They hate tap water.
They only like sugary water."
What are the odds of getting
such a picky dead bee?
[ Laughter ]
You give it tap water,
he turns into Gordon Ramsay.
Just, "[Spits] Ah! it's bland!
This water is bland!"
So, I mixed sugar with water
to make simple syrup.
I'm a mixologist now
for a dead bee.
And I put the sugary water
on a spoon.
But it won't drink it.
This dead bee has lost
its thirst.
So, I just start splashing
its corpse,
just covering its dead body
in a sticky liquid,
dishonoring its memory
completely.
And the whole time, my
girlfriend is over my shoulder
like, "Is it working?"
And I go,
"No, it's not working."
And she goes, "Why not?"
I go, "Because it's dead.
It's a dead bee."
And I know it was dead
because I had killed it
with a magazine
earlier that day...
[ Cheers and applause ]
when he came
into my home uninvited.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it!
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you do it.
That's how you do it, brother.
Fantastic.
Colum Tyrrell, everybody.
His podcast is available
on YouTube.
We'll be right back, everybody.
Come on back.